[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be doing
some rankings
except instead of power we're going to
be ranking intelligence
now first things first intelligence can
be measured in a lot of ways
someone might have a genius level iq but
be completely inept at doing certain
things
or feeling certain ways and so this is
somewhat delicate territory
there's wisdom accrued over many years
of simply
living life cunning academic smarts and
even
emotional intelligence with none of them
necessarily being more important
than the other all of the characters in
this list have their own
unique strengths so for the following
rankings
all i'm going to try and do is determine
how well rounded these characters are
if someone is supremely wise but lacking
in everything else
then they drop down and the same goes
for any other
type of intelligence i'd love to hear
your top ten
so pause the video comment your own top
10 below
then watch the rest and see how your
list compared to mine
without further ado i present the top 10
most
intelligent harry potter characters
number 10
remus lupin remus lupin was a british
half-blood wizard born in the year 1960.
like most others he attended hogwarts
and it was there that he befriended the
other members of the marauders
at a very young age remus was attacked
by notorious werewolf
fenrir greyback infecting him with
lycanthropy
however despite suffering from such a
traumatic experience early on in his
life
it certainly didn't stunt his
development into a wise
caring and talented man remus was a very
talented wizard
and was able to accomplish quite a lot
magically at a very young age
among other things remus was a talented
duelist charms expert
and defense against the dark arts master
having successfully taught a class on it
at hogwarts remus was one of the wisest
mentors that harry ever had
and i believe that his cunning wisdom
knowledge
makes him entirely deserving of a spot
on this list
number nine lily evans lily potter born
in lily evans
was an english muggleborn witch born in
the year 1960.
most notably she was the mother of harry
potter
and one of the main reasons for
voldemort's initial downfall
lily excelled in school and quickly
became widely recognized
as an extremely powerful witch in fact
voldemort attempted to recruit lily to
the death eaters
in spite of the fact that she was a
muggleborn a true testament to her
abilities
not only was she talented she had an
affinity for learning
and while gryffindors can have that
trait as well i could totally see her in
ravenclaw
she performed well in all classes potion
making
charms and even transfiguration there
wasn't much that could stop lily
her most notable and certainly most
impressive accomplishment to date
was her loving sacrifice which allowed
harry potter to live
simultaneously killing voldemort for a
time
number eight sirius black sirius the
godfather of harry potter and member of
the black family
started at hogwarts in the year 1971.
while many of his family members placed
an unreasonable amount of value on blood
purity
sirius did not share this same belief he
was certainly wise beyond his
years and his ability to think for
himself rather than blindly following in
the footsteps of his family
speaks to his character and intellect
sirius
despite messing around while at school
still did exceptionally well
and the fact that he was able to get
away with sucking off just tells us how
smart sirius really was
imagine if he had applied himself
unfortunately sirius's magical
development was somewhat stunted
by the extensive amount of time that he
spent in azkaban
but on the flip side his high level of
intelligence meant
that he was still able to become a very
powerful wizard number 7.
slughorn professor horace slughorn was a
british wizard who worked at hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry
slughorn was a highly respected wizard
who served as both potions master
and head of slytherin house he was a
brilliant man and perhaps one of the
most talented potioneers of his time
his downfall however was that he would
often overlook people who weren't of
value to him that is famous
exceptionally talented
or somehow important slughorn was a
triple threat he was cunning
wise and book smart however one of the
biggest issues with slughorn is of
course that he shared some of this
knowledge
with tom riddle ultimately inadvertently
helping him to achieve
horcrux's creation number six luna
lovegood
luna is a bit of a wild card here and
you may not have expected to see her
but luna whose mind was truly open to
anything left
no stone unturned when it came to
learning and it's this curiosity that
warrants her position on this list
yes she's often portrayed to be a bit
loony
but luna is deeply intelligent always
able to see the bigger picture
and never distracted by trivial things
that may hinder someone else's
intellectual development
she was a smart quick thinker with an
open mind and aptitude for solving
complex puzzles
number five mcgonagall minerva
mcgonagall was a scottish half-blood
witch that attended hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
and later worked there while she
attended hogwarts she was the most
talented student of her entire year
and she achieved top grades in her newts
and owls
she exhibited extreme magical prowess
from a very young age
and later became one of hogwarts best
professors
mcgonagall is just massively intelligent
in every respect
wise book smart emotionally intelligent
she had it all
number four tom riddle voldemort is
undoubtedly one of the most powerful
if not the most powerful dark wizard in
the entire harry potter universe
born tom marvolo riddle in 1926 voldon
began attending hogwarts in 1938
and was sorted into none other than
southern house from a very young age it
was clear that tom was special
a magical prodigy he was able to utilize
and control magic without the use of a
wand
had the power to move objects with his
mind and was able to communicate with
and control animals
all without any kind of magical training
he was the savant of magic
outperforming the feats of trained
witches and wizards with no prior
knowledge on the subjects
he excelled in school and was thought by
all to be incredibly bright
in his life he achieved many
accomplishments thought previously
impossible
most likely due to his innate magical
ability and thirst for knowledge
voldemort was massively cunning
and could expertly use his intellect to
manipulate people
however the reason he isn't high on the
list is that sometimes
he could be fairly short-sighted he was
also massively emotionally
unintelligent he was too preoccupied
with achieving power
that he would sometimes make foolish
mistakes and it's his lack of wisdom
and emotional intelligence that prevents
him from climbing higher
number three severus snape severus snape
was born in the year 1960
to a mughal father and witch mother he
began attending hogwarts in 1971
along with harry's mother milly potter
as well as the marauders
right off the bat tragedy struck snape
as he was sorted into slytherin
while his love interest lily was sorted
into gryffindor
at a young age snape began practicing
the dark arts
fueled by rage stemming from incessant
bullying at the hands of the marauders
snape was already a very talented young
wizard and excelled in all subjects
however the bullying that he received
pushed him to a new level
and he became obsessed with being the
best the smartest
he wanted to teach those boys a lesson
while learning his primary course
material at hogwarts
snape would scribble in his notebook and
invent curses
charms and potions his own potions
textbook complete with his own creations
under his alias
the half-blood prince contained many
powerful spells that he created
himself which is no easy feat snape's
biggest strength was his cunning
he could outsmart and deceive anyone if
he wanted to
and the fact that he was able to play
double agent for so long speaks to this
snape even after finishing at hogwarts
never stopped learning
and it's his continual development that
allowed him to achieve some extremely
impressive
magical feats number 2. hermione granger
hermione granger was one of the most
talented witches of her entire year
and the entire school for that matter in
fact hermione may have been one of the
most studious
and brightest witches to have ever
graced hogwarts
she began attending hogwarts at the same
time as harry ron
and given her affinity for learning and
knowledge it's no surprise that she
became a talented witch
she had a thirst for knowledge and
through her dangerous adventures with
harry and ron
became ready for anything and everything
that came her way
she was well-rounded competent and a
quick thinker able to think critically
under all kinds of pressure
not only was she studious she was just
naturally very intelligent
things came easily to her and her
inquisitive nature only meant
that she stockpiled all manners of
information hermione's only drawback and
perhaps one of the reasons that she
isn't at the top of the list
was her narrow-mindedness and inability
to sometimes see things from other
people's perspective
she was almost too smart for her own
good number one is
you guessed it albus dumbledore now i'm
sure you saw this coming
and i think that regardless of how you
value intelligence dumbledore has to
at least be in your top five he is
unquestionably one of the most powerful
wizards to have ever lived
and it was apparent almost right away
that he would achieve great things
while at school dumbledore's magical
abilities consistently turned heads
particularly his skills surrounding
charms and transfiguration
he also did exceptionally well on his
newts and owls
griselda marchbanks a professor working
for the wizarding examinations authority
remarked that albus was able to do
things with the wand that she had never
seen before
dumbledore had it all he was remarkably
wise very bright
cunning tactical and even emotionally
intelligent
he missed things here and there but with
such a curious and inquisitive mind
i'm sure he had a lot on his plate and
that's it for my top 10 list honorable
mentions go out to flitwick
shacklebolt moody and some of the
weasleys i'm sure i'm missing some
others but this is all i can think of
right now
i hope you enjoyed the video please like
and subscribe to support the channel
until next time your wizard harry